let's hear from joe from pittsburgh hi
rich and adam
joe from pittsburgh even with the
question of schools reopening unresolved
many parents have already made the
decision to homeschool or use cyber
school this fall
myself included any thoughts or tricks
on how to maintain
sanity while both working and being a
part-time teacher during this
time in history thanks guys and feel
free to use this clip on the air
so also that was echoed by bill lawrence
on facebook who was asking for advice on
resources for home schoolers because he
knew that you and julie
did that at one point yeah yeah yeah so
thanks bill and joe for that question
it's it's kind of a two-part question
one is homeschooling resources and the
other
is how to kind of maintain sanity as a
parent when you're trying to work and
also homeschool kids
it's tough you know i don't know that i
have the the ultimate answer to that
you do but as somebody here you can lock
yourself in the container i have a
shipping container and i
lock myself in it like a womb and i say
don't bother me
seems to work pretty well um at the same
time julie and i
have spent some time homeschooling our
kids and we both have worked
from home for quite a while so we have
some experience in this so
the first thing is is maintaining your
sanity and i think
um now that everybody is or a lot of
people are working from home now and
that's a new thing
i think it's important to have
boundaries around what is work time and
what is
homeschooling time or or uh leisure time
right because when you're working from
home it can all bleed into
they all bleed into each other and then
you're kind of always working and never
really working
and and a lot of times you're not 100
present in whatever you're doing because
these things are overlapping so
rule number one is establish your work
hours
and during those times that's when
you're focused on
your profession right and
that also requires you to
you know communicate adequately with
everybody in your family your kids and
your partner or whatever so that
everybody understands
these are the hours when you're doing
this thing and here are the hours we're
going to be doing these other things
and also i think it's important to
still create um
a little bit of structure around this
beyond just the scheduling like don't
just sit in your pajamas all day like
you know it's easy to fall into a kind
of depressive melancholy when you're at
home all the time
and just getting dressed like you would
for a normal work day or just
maintaining some of those practices i
think are important
in maintaining your sanity as well in
terms of
homeschooling resources
look education is shifting as professor
galloway will tell you
coronavirus is an accelerant
on online learning right like a lot of
the
traditional structures around education
i don't think are gonna come back i
think
there's gonna we're gonna see a lot of
mid-tier colleges go out of business
i think we're going to see this push
towards more and more online learning
and we're going to see a maturation of
the technological platforms that are
conducive to that
and people are starting to realize that
a lot of the cost that goes into
education
isn't really paying dividends like are
you really going to pay
you know 80 000 a year to send your kid
to usc
when it's basically zoom calls like
right that's gonna
you know that's gonna really uh upend
the paradigm here so this is being
exacerbated and accelerated by
coronavirus and we're not going to
just pivot back to the normal that we
knew before
like these changes are only going to
accelerate so
what i'm saying by that is that online
learning is going to become more the
norm
than the abnormality that doesn't mean
that kids aren't going to
eventually go back to the classroom they
will of course at some point i don't
think it's going to be this fall for
very many people
so we're in this for the long haul uh
in terms of homeschooling resources i
mean julie and i
are our paradigm with our kids when they
were younger was very much an
unschooling methodology
so it wasn't a lot of you know kumon and
all kinds of online learning
courses we have tutors we and we we
still do for
for jaya who's homeschooled we have a
couple tutors
that she spends time with every week and
works on projects
and and she has some online um
stuff that she does through those tutors
but i don't have like a list of
you know these are the websites that you
go to does giant giant been
home schooled this whole time she has
been okay well she was at
a school she was at muse for a while and
now she's been homeschooled now for
like the last two years oh wow mathis
goes to
an art high school in downtown but now
that's all on zoom
and it's been very difficult because the
appeal of this art school was all the
studio time and the dark room time and
all the practical
you know art based education that she
was receiving there that was her
lifeblood and now it's just
zoom from you know 8 30 in the morning
to
4 o'clock at night and it's making her
insane and i don't blame her you know
kids are not wired for that so
to the extent that we're trying to mimic
that classroom experience
by dent of a screen i think is a mistake
i think what we need to do
is leverage the unique opportunities
that are available to us to do something
a little bit more creative and unique
with with our children's education
one of the things that i think is one of
the opportunities i think we have is to
create
a more experiential based learning
experience for kids where
we look at what their this is particular
especially to younger kids like look at
what they're
naturally interested in like what are
they inclined towards when they're not
being told
they have to learn something like what
are they what it what are the things
that they're into is it comic books is
it
you know drawing pictures is it you know
making beats on you know garage band
like what do they do
when no one's looking and then try to
figure out
how to create some kind of learning
experience curriculum
that involves that avenue that
involves that discipline right and use
that
to teach everything from math to english
right like if somebody wants to make
beats well there's an opportunity to
teach them math
music is math right create compositions
learn about
musical notes and how they relate to
math and you know
figure out a way to you know translate
the emotional experience of making music
and listening
music into words that can become an
essay like i
i really believe in in moving towards
their natural interests and trying to
figure out
um how to how to platform that
into a greater understanding that
involves
other disciplines it's a
multi-disciplinary approach it requires
a lot of attention and time on behalf of
the parents
but i think that's how you get kids
engaged in learning
by focusing on what they're already
interested in
rather than trying to compel them to be
interested in something
that they're not oh you mean like the
american ethic of freedom
um what do you mean by that you have to
at least an hour a day
i want them to be indoctrinated on how
freedom is so vital
okay um that's important uh no but i
think it's really interesting it reminds
me of an old
outside magazine article that i read it
was like about unschooling his kids like
he
he moved out to the woods with his wife
and his two young kids
and the whole idea was they weren't
going to homeschool they were going to
unschool
yeah and they were just going to live
off the land and do the best they could
and there's like a movie about that with
v remember
yeah well yeah the captain fantastic
that's different i mean captain
fantastic he ran a real school
right he did yes those kids were more
like that movie hannah
yeah it's like survival that was right
it was different
that was like specific type of
homeschooling captain fantastic meets
like the girl with the dragon tattoo
um but uh i think that's really
interesting
not mimicking normal school what you
what you pointed to there that's
liberating for parents because i think a
lot of people
want to do that because they think and
it's also that goes for don't mimic the
normal work day
like you like you said you need to be
able to
be okay with working four or five hours
maybe instead of eight and do it in a
really concentrated fashion and then do
the same thing with the schooling
um you know maybe a morning session an
afternoon session and just like move the
these are all moving parts they don't
have to look the same way that they did
yeah yeah and there's a lot of fear with
that i've experienced this myself
because i'm a product of a very
traditional education
and i'm a successful product of that
system right
i went to prep school and i went to
fancy colleges and i went to law school
and so when i look at my kids i think
well they
need to have that experience or you know
i need to make sure
that the value that i experienced is
part of their upbringing
and for me it's been a process of
letting go of a lot of that
because in truth the educational system
is right for a reboot yeah we're dealing
with the legacy of a system that was
created
you know at the dawn of the industrial
age to
basically create productive create a
productive workforce that was capable
and it really hasn't evolved much past
that in any real tangible way now
we have this moment this interruptive
moment
in which we have the opportunity to
really
evaluate the validity of this system
and reimagine and reinvent it and i
think
you know the hurdle for me has always
been well if we're doing this
unschooling method or if we're doing you
know
pursuing this in a in a relatively
untraditional way like are they going to
know how to do math are they gonna i had
these
fears like well they're not gonna learn
about you know
like pick any subject matter right
but when i really thought about it i
thought well education doesn't really
appreciate
the value of the technological tools
that are
at our behest now everybody's got a
super computer
in their pocket yeah that has the answer
to every question they ever
want asked and answered so
this modality of read and memorize
seems completely ludicrous in light of
that
yeah and what we need to do is is focus
more on
critical thinking skills life skills
leadership skills like how do we produce
a well-rounded
self-sustaining individual with solid
self-esteem
and leadership skills and the ability to
listen
and the ability to learn and a love of
learning like what you want to do is
create
somebody who will become a lifelong
learner if somebody's enthusiastic about
learning
and you have a phone or a laptop your
education
doesn't have a start point and an
endpoint this is something you will have
your entire life so how can we instill
that in young people how can we get them
excited about learning and
again it goes back to what i said at the
outset which is focus on the things that
they're interested in
and demonstrate to them that no matter
what that interest is
it's it's like a seed that can then
blossom or flourish into learning about
many different anything because it could
intersect with all these other disorders
everything intersects with everything
else right it's one big web
i like that that's really good and i
like um what you said about mid-level
universities because i always knew that
trump university wasn't that university
it was the time it was if if he launched
it now
it would be a huge hit gonna be a huge
hit maybe
[Music]
you